真的很神奇
就是一个日本的企业。
他要给自己本国的人去销售一个产品。
但是他花了30年的时间在中国拍广告。
讲述中国的故事
去卖一个实际上还是一个日本的产品。
所以三德丽在营销的时候。
他就决定了说
我这个产品一定要和中国强榜定。
很多日本观众在认识中国的时候。
也都深刻的被这一30年的乌龙茶广告所影响到了。
我觉得这种桃花园这种距离感。
真的就是中国特别美的一面。
然后也是我们可以去发掘的一面。
hello大家好。
欢迎来到这期的怀度写真机。
我是海读
我是静雅
那么今天我们想和大家来聊一个。
有关中国的很特别的拍摄项目。
他横跨了将近30年的时间。
然后塑造了非常经典的有关中国的影像。
但是很神奇的是这个影像。
大多数时候都没有被中国的观众所看到过。
他背后的故事也没有被大家所熟知。
所以今天我们就想来和大家聊一聊这个故事。
是的
然后这个故事的主人公。
我觉得所有人应该都会非常熟悉。
他就是来自于日本的三德丽的乌龙茶。
然后我觉得这个茶应该。
大家游戏到了夏天都会去饮用。
然后我们俩现在在录制的过程中。
也在喝这个乌龙茶。
我觉得对于很多中国人来讲。
就是三德丽的乌龙茶简直是再熟悉不过了。
但是可能大家都没想过。
就是他从1984年开始。
一直到2011年12年左右。
将近30年的时间里。
他基本所有的广告都是在中国取景。
然后找中国的模特拍摄的全部是中国的故事。
然后他的这些所有的。
无论是电视广告还是摄影的平面广告。
也全部都是给日本的观众去看的。
给日本的消费者
让他们去消费这个产品。
同时去认可三德丽茶饮的这个品牌的。
对 所以我觉得这个事就特别的神奇。
因为我最早有印象开始喝这个产品。
是在可能2011年的时候。
就是刚上大学
然后突然间三德丽乌龙茶的这个方形的瓶子。
就一下铺满了所有的便利店。
开始能很容易的买到它了。
因为之前它好像用的是一个类似于统一的原型的瓶子。
然后铺货也很少
我在平时的生活间很难见到它。
但是后来就发现这个东西它确实很好喝。
因为它那个乌龙茶味做的还挺正的。
然后就能稳定的买到它。
在我的记忆中
这三德丽的乌龙茶是我开启。
无糖茶饮的一个启蒙。
就是可能在它之前喝的都是什么统一的。
冰雾茶 绿茶
后来就一下子开始长大了。
长大了之后去七一一什么各种便利店里面。
就出现了这个东西。
就虽然我们也没有看过关于它的广告。
但是当我们今天重新去回顾有关。
三德丽乌龙茶的这个广告。
它的影像 摄影的这些故事的时候。
又觉得不仅就是学到了很多。
也有很多的感慨
甚至有很多的感动。
大家如果看过三德丽乌龙茶的这个瓶身的话。
会发现它会特别标注自己的茶叶。
是产自于中国福建省。
然后这是它特别重的一个产品标签。
那个时候我就觉得这个产品做得好好。
就是刚认识这款产品的时候。
就会觉得中国的茶叶。
原来做成品装茶也能很好喝。
因为最开始喝这种品装的无糖茶饮。
可能大家都不太接受。
都会觉得没有家里那么冲泡着好吗？
那其实不止我和中国的消费者们是这么想的。
最初在日本刚推出乌龙茶这个产品的时候。
日本观众也这么想。
那这个故事就说来话长了。
它最早要回溯到1984年左右。
这个是三德丽公司。
它决定开发一个新的产品领域。
这也是昭和时代日本人特别爱干的一个事嘛？
就是会去做一些奇思妙想的怪产品出来。
那那个时候三德丽就觉得。
酒这个产品已经被他们推得差不多了。
因为那个时候他们刚刚发起了一波。
有关于三德丽威斯基的这个宣传。
然后当然到现在为止。
三德丽威斯基也是一个特别棒的产品嘛？
所有人都很认可他会议价。
然后那那个时候他们就想喝酒类似的一个东西。
又是这种虎破色的。
然后想开发一个出来。
于是就选中了茶饮这个方向。
因为正好是一个非常健康的饮料。
是跟酒背道而驰的。
同时呢在那个时候日本人喝茶。
也大多数像中国人之前一样是在家里喝的。
大家不会说走在路上去买一个茶饮料。
在1984年的日本茶饮料还是一个很新鲜。
然后很挑战传统观念的产品。
于是三德丽就正式开始了。
他们关于中国的长达。
将近30年的这样的一个影像的。
或者说广告的这样的创作。
我觉得这个事情真的特别能够激发。
我们作为一个观众的好奇心。
因为真的很神奇
就是一个日本的企业。
他要给自己本国的人去销售一个产品。
但是他花了30年的时间在中国拍广告。
讲述中国的故事
去卖一个实际上还是一个日本的产品。
那我就特别特别好奇。
他这30年到底是怎样记录了中国。
记录了中国的什么样的场景。
什么样的面貌
然后可以让日本人或者说更多的外国人。
非常喜欢这样的一个产品。
甚至因此认识了中国。
那我们就从1984年开始吧？
在1984年的时候。
三德丽打算做乌冻茶饮料这个项目。
他们选择的产品路线。
其实这时候起了一个很决定性的作用。
他们认为就是如果要做的话。
要做一个高档一点的茶。
就像他们去做Whiskey也是酒里面。
比较贵一点的
阳气一点的
带有海外标签的这么一个东西。
那在传统的茶叶里。
比如未发酵的是绿茶发酵的就是红茶。
但是技术难度上最高的。
是乌冻茶这种半发酵茶饮。
你要发酵到一半
然后控制好它的温度。
控制好它的发酵程度上停止它的发酵过程。
所以这个在中国古代。
大家把乌冻茶作为一种贡品。
上贡给皇上去喝
以及认为它是一个高级茶饮。
其实是从这种很技术的角度出发的。
所以三德丽在选定茶饮料方向的时候。
就决定要做这么一款高级的东西。
选定了乌冻茶
那么其实对于全世界的茶饮爱好者来讲。
大家都知道
说乌冻茶这个东西一定是中国产的最好。
因为你看其他茶饮料。
传出去到英国或者到日本。
他们都没搞出来半发酵这种这么高级的玩意儿。
然后所有人都知道一定是福建的乌冻茶最好。
在伍仪山还有安西这两个地方。
产出铁观音
这些都是已经非常有市场认知度的东西了。
那日本人其实在明治时代就1900年纪念的时候。
他们那个时候通商已经通得很好了。
也就知道了说
中国有这种高级茶叶就是福建产的就是乌冻茶。
所以三德丽在营销的时候。
他就决定了说我这个产品一定要和中国强榜定。
而且他确实也做到了就是他的所有茶叶原料。
以及他的这个采摘后的处理全部是在中国完成的。
他在烘焙之后
都已经做好成品茶叶了。
才再运到日本的工厂。
或者在中国的一部分工厂去做处理。
那他们这么注重于一个原产地概念的产品。
想必整个视觉方案也非常的原产地。
对吧？
就我猜也是非常的中国化。
对
所以就来讲一下他乌冻茶产品。
在日本的第一个阶段的广告。
就是以传统中国风格的插画为主。
去展示的
那他这个广告的系列持续了四年。
然后日本人会管他叫大人片。
就是中国人说什么大人。
您是张大人
您是王大人
您是李大人的大人的意思。
就是清朝的官员那种。
是吧？
就是他是极品极品的官员。
但是他一定是一个古代中国的一个形象。
对
然后他就是那种清朝官员的顶带花云。
然后留着小胡子的这么一个形象。
然后我看了一下
他还有一种就是中式的山水画的漫画式的改编。
因为这个人物的背景是一个山水画的感觉。
但是他的整个构图明显又不是中国传统国画的构图法。
就变得一下子很现代。
对
所以在那个时候
其实后来负责这个广告的艺术总监。
也就是AD
他是日本非常著名的一位艺术总监。
获过很多奖叫做葛西勋。
那他接受采访的时候就说。
说当时乌冻茶产品给到他的时候。
他是打算去在中国做实景拍摄的。
但是因为在84-85年的时候拿不到进入中国的许可。
他没法带整个的剧组进去。
然后那个时候个人名义去中国是可以的。
但是那个时候确实作为一个外国的设置团队。
你要到中国来
然后还要找中国人去当模特。
然后你去拍平面
还要拍视频
这是一个对当时的中国来说比较困难的事情。
那么前四年等于葛西勋是因为没有达成去中国拍实景的愿望。
所以才只能拿这种漫画改动化的方式。
然后做一下折衷
然后这个广告能持续四年。
他当然在内部也要多少做一点变化。
不能拿一只大人的脸。
就是贯穿了四年
所以他渐渐地将大人动起来了。
然后在影片的最后拿着玻璃的高脚碑。
喝起了乌冻茶
然后在第一年是大人一个人。
第二年是大人和他的妻子。
第三年是大人妻子和他们的女儿。
一家三口的这么一个状态。
然后到第四年他们还会特意的在访谈里说。
因为中国是独生子女政策。
所以不能说再多个儿子了。
所以给女儿招个女婿。
组成了一个四口之家的形象出现在屏幕上。
幸好他们没有第五年。
因为如果第五年的话。
估计就有第三代人了。
所以就第一个阶段。
其实我理解还是一个比较漫画风。
但是他其实是非常深刻地奠定了一个中国式的一个基调了。
当事件来到了1987年。
然后三德丽乌冻茶。
关于中国的影像的创意。
就来到了一个真正的实拍的阶段了。
对吧？
对
在87年他们终于第一次。
进入到中国实拍的许可。
所以他们就开始了中国实景的影像创作。
那么这个时候葛齐勋还是比较仓促。
团队没有准备的比较充分。
先去拍了一些像纪录片一样的东西。
所以头两年的87和88年。
他们其实分别拍了在福建摘茶叶的女工。
和在工厂里进行茶叶分件和烘焙工作的景象。
其实这也是他们非常想强化的一个很产品的信息嘛？
还是就是说我这是一个特别中国的产品。
我把我产品的源头都展现给观众看。
以此尽量说服给大家。
因为其实前面这个大人篇也是同样的逻辑。
那个大人篇的形象呢？
在明治时期1900纪年的这个海报里好像就出现过。
这也是他们从一个古老的形象里划采出来的。
所以那到这个部分为止。
可以都是说他们在很直接的展示有关中国的元素。
来把中国这个概念和三德地翁茶进行一个强绑定。
然后放给日本的观众看。
我觉得当时的这个广告也特别有意思。
他就翻译过来就是叫茶叶主义。
因为当时他这个设置组能够到中国拍广告。
广告又是一个与时俱进的一个东西。
他不是说我过来拍一个过去的故事。
或者说是一个虚构的电影。
他是一个很现实的。
然后与时代紧密相连的这样的一个内容。
那肯定也是当时的中国希望去展现给外国人。
看的这样的一面
所以你看像在吴亦珊采茶的姑娘。
对吧？
然后在这种大自然的状态下。
然后快乐的劳作的这种状态。
以及在工厂里面
就是非常社会主义的工业化的这样的场合中工作的女性。
其实也是当时的中国想要展现给外国人看的。
也是一种非常青春。
非常美丽的一个感觉。
那么到此为止
其实三德地吴亦珊采所做的这些影像概念。
还比较的在大家的意料之中。
就是他还没有走上非常放飞。
或者说特别能大动人的点。
因为他可能也只是说换了个去境地嘛？
但是在日本已经获过很多广告讲的。
葛西勋肯定是不满足于这个事情的。
所以在1990年开始。
这个广告发生了一个巨大的变化。
就是葛西勋终于把这个队伍凑齐了。
把人摇齐了
然后他找来了大家可能非常熟知的上天一宴去做摄影师。
因为这些年其实大家会看到上天一宴。
经常来到中国办很多的活动。
他在过去所拍到的很多很多的影像。
其实都是中国人都非常喜欢的这种过去的中国。
像一种乌托邦甚至是桃花园式的一种中国的美丽。
但实际上他所拍摄的这些中国的影像。
基本所有的行程或者说是内容。
都是和丹德丽的乌龙茶强相关的。
那么上天一宴可能是这几年吧？
在中国非常广泛地走入到大家的视野里了。
大家如果去那种高级一点。
会有艺术画册的书店里。
肯定会看到上天一宴的作品。
然后甚至看到中国出版社给他出的。
非常精美印刷的这种珍藏版作品。
比如他的铝鱼
比如他的永远要充景。
这些都是由中文直接作为一个语言版本出现在书里面的。
同时呢？
比如他也经常最近跑到云南河西藏去拍照。
然后可能很多人会在莱卡的大事班。
或者送在那个酒店的活动里见到上天一宴。
那其实这也证明了上天一宴确实。
一个是在中国很火。
另外一个是他喜欢中国。
回过头来来说
他为什么会这么跟中国有强相关。
其实确实就是三德地乌龙茶这个广告带给他的。
在他90年贝克金勋邀请加入这个项目的时候。
他也是一个新人摄影师。
新到就是刚刚出了第一套自己的作品。
刚有一个比较完整的项目展现给行业。
都不能说是展现给了公众。
然后那那个时候
葛齐勋看到了上天一宴的肖像作品。
然后就觉得这个年轻人拍得很好。
是不一样的风格
于是就去联系了他。
把他邀请在了
那上天一宴
大家可能现在看他。
是带着多摩美术大学前教授的这个头衔。
然后是一个非常得高望重的行业前辈。
但是那个时候
他其实是一个很年轻。
很没有话语圈的这么一个人。
那葛齐勋在把他邀请在之后呢？
又拉上了之前一直在乌龙茶这个项目里。
为他撰写文案的安藤龙。
然后那么像这样
刚才说的很多有趣的。
像柴主义这样的slogan。
然后都是安藤龙去想出来。
然后放到每一期的文案里的。
那这个时候作为文案。
然后艺术总监以及摄影师或者说摄影指导的这个组合。
就正式的形成了
那葛齐勋挑中上天一宴的点。
是在于他认为上天一宴所表达的那种距离感。
是很新鲜的是在其他广告摄影师里所看不到的一个东西。
葛齐勋在当时就是想启用一个展新的视角。
不同于日本传统广告的视角。
来诠释他手头的这个乌龙茶的项目。
那当上天一宴加入到了这个团队之后。
他们的影像开始发生了怎样的变化。
然后他们又开始去拍摄了中国的什么呢？
当上天一宴加入进来之后。
可以从他的广告上明显的看到说。
拍摄的对象和场景都有了一个很巨大的变化。
因为之前一直是在跟茶叶有关的地方拍嘛？
但是到了90年的广告里就变成了去京剧院。
去拍摄正在训练表演的这些京剧演员的身影。
最后他们会搭成一个像很奇怪的造型。
然后屏幕上会蹦出来说散到这个乌龙茶。
当然在这个过程中其实慢慢形成了。
后面散到这个乌龙茶广告会有的一个风格。
就是首先在视频里面。
他的人物对白是不会有日文也不会有日文的字幕的。
全部是以庞黛或者演员对话的中文为唯一的这个声音来源。
然后同时呢他们会给这些广告配上。
以中文演唱的歌曲作为一个BGM。
然后一直的播放
然后只在最后的五到十秒左右出现日文去念出来的。
散到地乌龙茶的品牌名还有安藏龙写的这个slogan。
我的感觉是其实从这个阶段开始。
尤其是上田一燕的加入。
他们其实已经开始在去寻找中国的文化标签了。
你像第一阶段其实是可希勋这个团队。
当他还不能进入到中国拍摄的时候。
对中国的一种非常古代式的一个想象。
一种意测他选择的是这种清朝的大人。
然后到了第二阶段呢？
他们开始和中国的政府接洽了。
所以他们上来就要去表达说茶叶主义。
当时的中国给全世界的人的感觉一定是关于社会主义的。
一个社会主义的国家是什么样子的。
是绿水青山的
是有着年轻女工的工厂的这样的一个感觉的。
终于到了第三个阶段。
他们要从文化上面去寻找这种非常中国式的元素了。
所以他们选择了京剧。
我觉得对于外国人来讲。
像京剧啊 奇袍 熊猫 小龙包等等。
像我们看什么乱马。
就是这种以中国的人物为主人公的动画的时候。
其实他们所体验出来的中国元素主要围绕的都是这一些。
所以你就比如说对于中国人自己来讲。
可能90年代然后京剧也是一个比较即将过时。
即将退出历史舞台的一个文化元素了。
但是他依然是世界的人。
就是外国人去认知说。
这是一个中国的东西。
这是一个中国原产的产品的时候。
一个非常重要的文化标签。
确实我觉得也是日本人想表达自己。
会比其他外国人更懂中国。
所以他会在比如像奇袍 小龙包这种很表面的元素里头。
再往深里挖一挖
他选到了京剧这个东西。
那么在京剧这个排车场景之后。
从1991年开始。
其实三德丽武龙产的广告。
正是进入了和中国的一个超深度绑定的时期。
也是上天宴在这个项目里创作最丰盛的一个时期。
也是现在大家去观看这些有关上天宴的中国照片时。
所熟悉的那些场景。
那么从1991年开始。
其实它的拍摄对象首先有一个特别大的改变。
它从这种很有中国刻板形象的。
比如京剧演员或者工人或者跟柴有关的东西。
就变成了一个穿着有点像现在心中的一个。
这个柴的一个画面。
然后就变成了一个很新的一个很新的一个特别的画面。
穿着有点像现在心中式衣服的那种中式服装。
然后还是传统中国淡黄色色系的这么一个年轻女子身材很瘦肠。
她在一个原境是山水作为背景的这么一个场景里。
然后正在很自由的呆羽毛球。
然后她一边呆羽毛球一边还会说一些日本观众听不懂的中文。
到时候我们可以把这些照片放在收脑子里。
大家可以去看
我觉得她的这个装发其实是非常中国风的。
就是你现在看都觉得挺潮的挺好看的。
绝对不是那种特别老气或者是特别成就的一种质感。
但是她依然是一种中式的。
她绝对不是日式的或者是法式的一个装发。
我觉得这个是特别特别好的。
她没有那么成就但是她又非常的中国。
这个点我觉得可能对于很多中国人都很难去拿捏好。
但是她能够展现出来。
我觉得这个可能对于很多国外的品牌来讲其实挺难。
其实大多数的西方人她对于中国的意想。
就是像之前经常被诟病的那个。
单缝眼就是细长的眼睛、耽眼皮。
还有高权骨的一些模特的这种脸型。
就是可能中国人会觉得说你们为什么总觉得我们中国人就是这样的。
然后但是像三德丽的这个广告里面出现的人物。
或者说是这个上天一宴她所选择的这些模特。
或者她所选择的这个场景。
她都是非常美好的中国。
她不会说是非常刻板印象或者说是非常主观一段的。
甚至有点丑化的这种中国。
我觉得这也是为什么中国人也非常喜欢三德丽。
喜欢三德丽的乌龙茶的一个原因。
然后这也是为什么现在的人去看上天一宴的作品也非常喜欢的一个原因。
我觉得这点还是挺神奇的。
因为日本人在这个广告系列里所展现出对中国人什么是一个特别美的中国人。
什么是一个帅气的中国人的理解。
是跟中国人的梦想是能重合在一起的。
其实反过来说中国人对一个日本人长的是帅的。
应该是什么样美的是什么样也能很好的把握到日本人的那个神韵。
所以这个文化的交融会让人觉得非常有趣。
对 我们纵蓝三德丽所选择的中国的模特。
你就会发现这些模特就尤其是比如说女孩子。
她都是舞蹈学院选拔出来的很素颜的很年轻的这种女性。
然后她们都是身材非常高挑的很细长。
就和日本的这种很娇小的女性的感觉是完全不一样的。
这些女性都是那种个子高高的。
然后嘴里面再念到些什么？
然后很喜欢吃也很喜欢运动。
就是一种非常青春阳光然后无忧无虑的这种状态。
当然个子高高的
我觉得她所认为的中国女生的这种美就是这样子的。
包括男生也是
你一定是比日本的这个男性的体型要更加的宽阔嘛？
然后也要更加的高大。
就是因为中国当时的这些非常美的人吧我们称之为。
他们也是非常细长的非常瘦。
那其实这个点也是和他们的产品。
无龙茶可以让你保持一个很好的身材。
是香气和的
比细雨还要紧密
上一次也帮歌手
要去渐渐微波
那么这个广告在91年发生了一个转变之后呢？
方向继续维持下去了4年。
在接下来的929394年呢？
其实用了差不多的这个世界语言和表达方法。
但是呢？
它也像最开始大人篇的这4年的迭代一样稍微有些改进。
比如在92年这一篇呢？
其实它选择的就是一对年轻的情侣。
站在原景是高山的这么一个很漂亮的风景里。
然后两个人唱着这个中文的歌曲。
最后端起微无龙茶的这么一个造型。
那么92年这个广告的名字呢？
其实就叫East Timber有沒有。
它就是翻译成中文官方现在应该叫永远要充景。
这也就是上天宴这本关于中国的影集的名字的来历。
就是这个
然后同时呢？
这个East的梅窝其实是来自于日本一首传统的歌曲。
它最早可能是在1950纪年6纪年比较流行的。
但是后来把它改变成了中国的版本。
就用在了这一支92年的三德丽无龙茶广告里面。
然后所以呢？
很多可能看过上天宴影集的朋友知道这个名字。
那其实这个名字的出处是这样得来的。
我觉得这个年份就是从1911年开始。
现在回想起来应该也是有一些时代背景在的。
我们几乎就是在一个打开电视机。
就是有各种各样的日本的动画的这样的一个年代的。
就感觉那个时候
中日的关系真的是非常好。
特别是这种文化的交流是非常密切的。
所以也能可想而知为什么那个时候。
他们拍这个三德丽无龙茶有那么大胆的一些想法。
而且创意做的那么足。
同时也依然在表现中国特别美好。
特别向上很年轻的这样的一面。
那么后面93年和94年的主角分别变成了。
一对刚结婚的夫妻。
然后和家族一起拍合影。
以及三个姐妹
然后在路上骑自行车这么一个场景。
当然背景也都是非常优美的。
或者说非常中国传统的这种民居或者是山水。
那这个时候大家可能能从我们的语言中感受到。
因为这个时候整个视觉看上去还是比较平面的。
它是一个非常简单的背景。
然后加上前景非常漂亮的人做一些简单的动作。
那我觉得这个也是比较标志性的一个上天宴的风格。
或者说是隔期薰想要去突破日本传统广告的一个点。
这几年其实他们的拍摄地。
其实也从五仪山福建这种地方拓展到了更多的地方。
比如云南、桂林
都是这种风景非常优美的地方。
非常我觉得直到今天依然很能代表中国这种风景。
在此之后从95年开始。
他们的创作好像又继续的深入了。
从95年开始一直持续到05年。
其实是一个比较稳定的时期。
大家也可以看到这个时期有长达10年之久。
那么这个过程中其实整个的视觉重心发生了一些改变。
从这种很传统的静态感或者说又山水情调。
有漂亮的模特形象出现在静止画面里的感觉。
变成了一个更有生活场景气息的风格。
就比如从95年开始。
他们首先是回到了茶叶的菜摘地。
然后去拍了这个菜茶姑娘在船上很开心的这个样子。
我觉得三德丽乌龙茶真的很喜欢展现女性形象的这样的一个品牌。
如果大家去翻看一下视频的部分。
就是他们广告的视频的部分。
你会发现这些女性都好美。
然后好自信
然后甚至你看就是1999年的这个广告里面。
我看到是两个女孩他们在穿着旗袍。
然后这个旗袍那个叉开得可高了。
开到了快大腿跟那个位置。
然后他们俩一起就是特别快乐的。
非常自信的在一起跳舞。
当然他们一看也是非常专业的这种舞蹈演员。
包括之前他们有一些广告在这个对白里面。
然后这个主人公的女孩子就会说。
你看这个是地球上的男孩子给我的。
我觉得好神奇
他们对于人物的设定。
对于中国当时女生的这种形象的认知是非常正面。
然后甚至非常领先的。
然后包括像这个阶段的广告。
他们也会去聊很多这种家常。
然后自己的生活这些事情。
因为我觉得这些女孩特别的真实。
他们生活特别美好。
包括像上天一夜为人所知。
那个四个女孩在特别漂亮的林地里。
然后正在跳舞的这个场景。
也是在这个阶段拍出来的。
因为他们其实这个渠景的范围变得更广。
那么然后人物的动态也变大了。
然后那么从96年开始。
其实甚至他们还引容了明星。
他们在那个时候发掘到了路易。
到了97年是一个空姐的故事。
然后他们会在飞机上发工茶。
然后他们会回到宿舍里喝过工茶。
然后期待自己未来的人生是什么样子的。
到了后面他们的镜头还对准了母女。
还对准了在海洋边跳舞的姐妹。
然后到了00年的时候。
可能有一个影像上的很突兀的转变。
就是表演的痕迹可能会变得更重一点。
00年这支广告是姐弟两个人。
在类似于北京街头穿梭的这个自行车流里面。
然后逆着车流一边行走一边跳舞的。
怎么一个形象
我觉得其实跟大家那时候对千细年的期待。
可能也有关系对于时代的反叛。
或者说对于下个新时代的期待。
总想做出一些很有个性的事情。
是的
而且我觉得现在去回忆这些照片这些影像。
你都会觉得简直就是记录了中国的一个发展。
就比如说女性已经开始去当空姐了。
那其实她可能背后的背景也是中国的机场。
已经在与世界相连接了。
然后包括他们所有的空姐主题的广告的歌曲。
其实都是用的铁壁阿童木的这样的一个主题曲。
然后这个主题曲其实无论是对于日本观众。
还是对于中国观众来讲。
都是一个非常熟悉的旋律。
那他也通过这个广告。
非常神奇的把两个文化、两个国家的人连接在一起了。
进入千细年之后
其实虽然拍摄广告的思路没变。
但是依然还是有一些时代的印记会刻在里面。
那么01年的广告。
其实他们把镜头对准了两个开着小皮卡车。
然后卖蔬菜的姐妹。
那么02年是请了乐基尔去展示了上海。
现代女性的生活是什么样子了。
然后同时他们还在这支广告里用了。
东京之前非常流行的东京不给无给的改编版。
把它改编成了上海不给无给。
然后我们也可以放在这里给大家听一下。
那其实他整个的选曲。
然后还有他整个的所展现出来的时代情绪。
可能要比之前还要再积极。
或者说还要在世界更有活力一些了。
开始
上海不给无给
那姐姐无给无给
才行从曾经曾经挖哭挖哭。
中国妈妈大二会想着呢？
上海不给无给
对 我觉得包括这个乐基尔这个广告。
也特别的能够证明说。
就是三德丽乌龙茶仅跟中国试试。
因为乐基尔是香港人嘛？
香港和上海的连接。
就是经济啊？
包括文化的连接其实一直以来也都很强。
他这个时候其实也是香港和上海的这个关系。
然后包括中国更加国际化。
更加都市化的一面。
其实在呈现给世界。
然后他们又做了这样的一个女性的形象展现出来。
我觉得真的是非常与时俱进。
所以现在去看说广告摄影。
他对于现实的这种呈现。
或者我们说是打影号的这种美化。
其实也是一种时代的记录。
甚至广告的这种记录我觉得是更稳定的嘛？
它更可靠一点
因为它播出前
然后拍摄时
比如在中国应该都会接受多多少少的一点审核。
包括作为歌迹勋
然后作为上天演
他们也会更加把控好。
他作为影像方面的纯度。
他应该是精良的、优美的。
简单一懂的
但是又紧贴当下时代的。
其实这笔传统你做一个历史性的记录。
要经受更多的考验。
那么之后在03年。
其实他们把拍摄地搬到了哈尔滨。
我看这条广告的时候其实特别的怎么说呢？
感慨
因为我自己可能都没有见到过松花江结冰。
然后有人在上面滑冰的这个景象整个是什么样子的。
但是看到这个广告会让人特别的向往。
会觉得那是一个寂静。
然后深远
但是又人很有火力的那个样子展现在那里。
就是我作为一个中国人。
我超级喜欢这个广告。
我就像中国人重景北海道一样。
但是当你看哈尔滨的这个广告的时候。
你深刻地认识到这是一个中国的景色。
是两个中国人在上面滑冰。
我觉得这种画面真的是中国才独有的。
然后它其实也是一种让世界人去理解中国的一个世界语言。
因为你想我们讲到这里。
其实刚讲完20年左右。
可能20年不到的一个历程。
但是我们发现广告里区经已经很多了。
展现出来的中国也很多样。
同时这就是中国最大的一个特点。
它实在是太大了
北道有哈尔滨那样的景象给你。
是那样的故事风格。
然后到了福建又是另外一个东西。
同时天津
然后上海这种很城市化的一面。
北京有庞大的这种自行车车流。
这种很神奇的景象。
其实就很直观的能反映出中国是什么样子吧？
我觉得这不存在说广告就是一个片面的对美好的结局。
它通过系列广告是能做到一个深度与广度的表达的。
然后那么到04年呢？
他们再次启用了另一位明星。
当时是请到了孙丽。
在一个武术学校里练武术的场景。
然后这个时候可能他们的缠密思路。
稍稍有的一些变化开始。
他们会宣传这是一个女性在运动完了之后。
可以喝的饮料
这是一个健康的
同时可能跟运动场景有更多强关系的时候。
然后那么到了05年呢？
他们是选择了一个圆景。
然后有一个穿着漂亮绿色旗袍的女子。
在拉尔湖的这么一个状态。
那么这个时候她主打的概念是。
阴运调这种非常中国词汇的一个表达。
就很难想象她为什么要在一个茶叶广告里。
然后突出阴运调这个东西。
我觉得这明显就是一种日本人研究中国文化。
喜欢中国文化
喜欢模正了一种症状。
然后而且我觉得他们真的是请跟热点。
因为孙丽我记得当年。
她应该是2003年演的海洁的那个玉冠英。
然后特别火
而且她演了一个女警察嘛？
就是其实那个时候也是。
在影视上中国有一个新的女性形象展现出来了。
因为像玉冠英的那个形象可能和欧阳兰兰什么的。
可能也是不太一样的。
包括像女性的明月音乐家也出来了。
就我深度怀疑她可能就是女子12月访的成员。
就现在大家听到这些词都觉得非常古早。
但是在想想其实她真的是能够代表中国。
这些东西全部都是与时俱进的。
她不仅代表着说女性的这种形象。
她也代表着世界或者外国人。
日本人对于中国的认知。
对我看到那个二胡广告的时候。
第一反应是谈顿
就是那个时候特别流行中国要有中国特色的音乐。
要有这些配乐要插曲。
然后出现在大家的视听语言里面。
然后同时其实04年孙丽还拍了另外一个版本的广告。
是她跟那个传统动画大到天空里面。
孙悟空的那个形象一起演的。
两个人一起拿那个Apple的去听歌。
然后那个时候三道地在日本是有一个活动。
就是她会抽4000台Apple给她的幸运的顾客。
然后包括那个后来也以大到天空里面。
唐僧和宋空的角色单独出过一支广告。
那个时候其实你看哪怕他们是用广告形象。
要挑这种特别中式的东西来展现。
孙丽加上美国苹果的一个音乐播放器的产品。
同时又展现在日本的这个乌龙茶广告里。
就真的是一个好美好的时代。
我觉得可能很难再有这种中美日大融合的年代了。
大家能够和平友好的共创一下。
其实我在这支广告底下也看到了日本网友有评论说。
他们觉得这样的广告很美。
因为你想孙丽和孙悟空喝着乌龙茶。
然后听着Apple。
然后他们说希望日中美三国在现实生活中。
可以把政治解决好一点。
能让这样的美景真正多出现一些。
我知道了
他们在玩一个鞋音歌。
就是孙丽姓孙
孙悟空姓孙
三大丽也姓孙
他对吧？
他开头是那个孙
反正就是压上了是吧？
那么时间来到65年之后。
其实事情多多少少发生了一些微妙的变化。
可能大家对那个年代已经没有什么印象了。
因为能是20年前的事了。
但是我们这代人90后应该是还知道一点的。
那一年中国在很多城市都发生了反日游行。
因为那个年代是小全政府上台了。
所以中日关系开始变得很紧张。
然后有很多政治上的摩擦。
于是这也影响到了孙悟丽的广告拍摄。
可能05年的广告他们有很多条。
就不得不用看紧的时候拍到的空镜。
来作为正式广告的内容。
同时他只能用一些特效。
然后逼一些产品上去来解决这个开天窗的问题。
在05年之后呢？
其实就因为有政治的影响。
然后广告的思路也开始有了调整进入了一个新的阶段。
从06年到09年。
其实6789又是4年。
对于这个三德丽来说可能40一个循环。
这4年间呢？
他用了一套新的语言或者说表述方法去介绍他这个产品。
但是依然有着非常重的中国元素在里面。
那这个阶段还是上天一晏在他的团队里吗？
从画面上来看
我觉得还是有上天一晏在的。
因为其实如果
对摄影非常热衷的朋友把06年07年这两年的无冻茶广告跟上天宴后来拍的。
Ethome这个个人项目去相比的话。
你会看到很多取景以及想表达上相近的部分吧？
然后那么在06年开始呢？
他开启了一个姐妹片。
故事的主人公呢变成了一对姐妹。
然后他们在06年呢是在餐桌上。
聊天闹家场
然后喝无冻茶
那么07年呢变成了这一对姐妹一起做料理在厨房里。
然后一边做饭一边扯家场一边最后喝无冻茶。
那么到08年呢这对姐妹又一起去为了保持一个好身材。
然后去练芭蕾跳舞。
跳舞之后呢他们说一起去吃个甜品吧？
然后吃甜面的时候再喝无冻茶。
那么到了09年呢这个时候妈妈就加入进来了。
就变成了母女两个人。
然后在这个生活中一起吃个甜品吧？
母女两个人
然后在这个生活中一起聊天。
然后看着风景
然后喝无冻茶
那在这四年的三道丽无冻茶广告里。
其实能看到
无冻茶已经变成了生活场景的一部分。
就无论是在你什么时候运动后啊？
还是做饭的时候啊闲聊的时候。
他都可以是被选择的一个营品。
这又跟上一阶段那种很活力。
然后很健康
那种女性独立一点。
这些主题又发生了一些新的变化。
我觉得从这也能看出来。
就是比较好的广告摄影。
它其实无论是AD啊还是摄影师。
它们从人物的塑造。
故事的背景
甚至画面的风格
其实都是想要引领一种趋势的。
想要去创造一种潮流的。
对我觉得这个其实是广告摄影。
特别有魅力的一点。
接下来这个广告系列就走向了它的终结。
这个广告系列是在2011年。
完成了它的最后一支广告拍摄。
在2011年采用的同样的主题。
都是请到了范冰冰。
然后同时还请到了张震。
张震是出现在2010年。
然后范冰冰是贯穿了这两年。
去拍了他们两个在厦门。
还有在香港去吃饭的时候的这么一个场景。
那其实这个时候呢？
大家在画面里已经看不到太多那种。
很中式优美的圆景风景。
整个镜头呢？
其实已经非常接近现在日本流行的一种。
类似于食品或者说饮料广告的状态。
就是在这个场景笔。
然后盯住这个明星的一举一动。
然后去拍它的情绪。
拍它对食物的感受。
然后就拍它引用饮料的这么一个画面。
然后这个阶段其实也是上天一夜拍摄了。
非常有名的范冰冰的那一套照片的这个时期。
范冰冰其实也是穿着非常中式的旗袍。
然后坐在一个非常中式的餐桌旁。
吃着中华料理喝着乌龙茶。
然后整个的打光非常的自然。
范冰冰其实它的整个形象也是一个。
非常中国女孩的一个状态。
这个其实也是不仅当时给日本的消费者留下了。
很深刻的印象
也让很多很多喜欢摄影的人。
直到今天也非常喜欢的摄影作品。
那么最后来到这个系列的终结。
它的终结也是有原因的。
也就是12年的时候。
中国其实又发生了一次比05年。
还要大的反日的浪潮。
那一次的浪潮可能对日本团队整个的影响也比较大。
而且这个项目其实已经持续了将近30年了。
所以在这个时候
三德力决定就放弃掉这个对乌龙茶的生产方向。
在第二年开始就选择。
美人拉克尔
然后这种很欧美的国际影像。
去在中日之外选一个第三方来代言自己的产品。
然后就让这个广告系列和中国做了一个告别。
到现在为止
我们终于算是梳理完了。
这长达30年的三德力乌龙茶在中国的创作。
那我们来总结一下吧？
所以其实我们最开始想来聊这个话题。
然后甚至激发了我们的好奇心。
其实还是因为上天一夜的作品嘛？
也是因为它最近几年在中国的走红。
它的这些照片不断的出现在各大书店。
社交网络
让很多人认识到说。
原来曾经的中国那么的美。
中国的人能够展现给世界看的这样的人。
是这么的美
然后我们从上天一夜的照片出发。
又去回顾了很多很多当时。
三德力乌龙茶的广告。
它的平面广告和电视广告。
然后发现了这么多。
有关中国的元素
竟然可以被这样的詮释或者说被这样的记录下来。
我觉得我们可以先聊一聊。
关于中国的元素这个点。
因为其实在我们自己的拍摄的时候。
我就是一个
虽然大家知道我们很喜欢看各种各样的摄影机。
我们会喜欢各种各样的摄影师。
欧美的 日本的
那可能对于我们自己创作而言。
我觉得最重要的
还是说我想要找到一个。
关于中国自己的摄影的风格是什么？
中国的色彩是什么？
中国的元素到底是什么？
甚至说我应该记录的中国人的面容。
应该是什么样子的。
其实这个一直是非常。
在这些年我在创作的时候。
我在摄影 在拍项目的时候。
让我特别挣扎
然后特别困惑的一个点。
就是我怎么才能够找到。
非常中国的一种影像。
尤其是摄影的一种风格。
因为我始终认为
摄影其实是一种非常现代化的艺术。
所以它对于一些
传统的文化的这种现代化的权势。
其实是更有优势的。
那我觉得我们就先从整个视觉。
影像的部分聊起吧？
我觉得如果想搞懂或者说。
体链出为什么这套广告这么吸引人。
为什么所有中国人看到了。
这个画面都会被吸进去。
那我觉得很重要的一个因素。
确实是上天验自己的这种摄影理念。
我们前面讲到过上天验。
其实是被葛极薰拉进来之后。
对画面风格有了很大改变。
它也是一个在当时日本广告界非常新人。
甚至非常叛逆的状态进来了。
那可能作为视觉来说。
这一点肯定是一切的起点。
或者说甚至能成为核心的。
那么就是上天验在很多采访里都表达过的。
他认为的美是什么样的。
他想拍什么样的景象。
什么触动他
他就一直说他想要一种距离感。
他并不是想要那种传统影棚里。
大光把人物物体打得很清晰。
你可以看到甚至出手可及的感觉。
他说他认为最美的光可能是从水底看到的那种光线。
他想要的是光经过一个物体慢慢被折射。
然后同时又有反射和散射。
一种信息从四面八方而来。
然后从整个画面的氛围里去传递信息的感觉。
而不是说我的画面里有物农场。
有人物
有一个特别漂亮的包装或者风景。
他就是我想传达的东西了。
同时这也是葛西勋最认可上天验的一点。
就是他可以把这种很好的距离感。
以及更沉浸的传达所表现出来。
他认为这是这个人在这个项目里最重要的那个环节。
那我们回到中国这个主题。
我觉得中国所有的元素。
其实我们现在想
无论你说是形状上的东西。
比如像建筑
比如说传统的文士。
比如传统的一些美术的形式。
然后再到色彩
比如说是一些红啊绿啊？
其实这些东西离我们的生活。
离甚至说80年代那个人的生活都很遥远。
中国就是他主要的文化输出的时代。
离大家很遥远
我觉得这是一个很微妙的契合。
契合了上天验的这种拍摄风格。
对 就是这种距离感真的很微妙。
它不仅是一个日本人对于中国的一个侠想。
对吧 这个侠想就是一种距离感。
然后它也是一种像一个现代人对于乌托邦。
对于桃花园的一种侠想。
然后这个侠想也是一种遥远的感觉。
也是一种你需要去探索。
你深入到了一个别人不知道的境地之后。
你才能发现这种独有的美的这种感觉。
同时还有就像你所说的。
对于中国的文化而言。
它也是一种比较遥远的感觉 对吧？
比如说这种非常大自然的东方的风景。
它对于全世界的人来讲。
它都是一种需要去深入。
需要去盘灯去探索的这样的一个风景。
然后你对于中国最璀璨的文化。
比如说唐宋的这个建筑。
然后书法 服饰等等。
它确实都是一种非常遥远的。
像梦一样的感觉
我觉得我们之前有去浙江一个。
比较古老的一个村落里面去拍摄。
然后当时就遇到了一个庙。
这个庙可能是一个宋代时期的一个老庙。
然后只有一个都不会讲普通话的。
一个老爷爷在看守。
当时我看到那个庙的时候。
整一个就是觉得我是不是踏入了一片桃花园。
我是不是进入到了一个非常梦境的场景里。
因为我看到的这个宋代的这个庙。
它整个的文士
它整个的状态和我在城市里。
看到的状态是完全不一样的。
尤其是如果你用这个庙去和比如说北京的。
很多皇家的建筑去相比的话。
那这个差距实在是太大了。
那当然它如果去和上海的更新的这些建筑相比。
它更像一个遥远的梦。
然后这个庙的正对面还有一个戏楼。
然后像这个戏楼
它还会拉着浅蓝色的沙莲。
当你看到那个场景的时候。
你就会期待一场非常正式的。
但是你已经不会再经历的记点。
或者是仪式在这个高台上发生。
那这个其实也是源于。
可能我们很多传统文化中的仪式感。
或者说是文化的传承已经不在了。
或者说它并没有被现代化。
所以当我们再去在一个非常。
你需要去深入探索的地方。
很难才能抵达的地方。
看到的这样的画面的时候。
你就会觉得它真的好像一个梦。
这就是桃花园吧？
那我觉得这种桃花园这种距离感。
真的就是中国特别美的一面。
然后也是我们可以去发掘的一面。
那么我在油管上
这些三德丽无农场广告的评论区里。
就发现很多日本网民会自发的。
就说这个广告里的中国就是桃花园。
就是桃园乡
他们也很认桃园名这个故事这个比喻的。
我看到这个时候我也觉得很神奇。
因为在中国人的一些文化的元素里。
其实日本是担任桃花园的那个角色。
很多人会说徐福当时放了秦志皇的命令去仿仙丹。
然后他到的就是日本。
然后在日本这种像世外桃园一样的。
于是隔绝的小岛上住下来了。
日本作为一个岛国也会给我们这种感觉。
我为什么在这能看到唐朝的东西。
宋朝的东西
他在保留些个什么？
然后反过来在这个广告的受众里。
观众会觉得那个中国让他特别的熟悉。
先进但又遥远
他觉得广告里展现出来的中国人是非常赤朴。
非常单纯的
他不需要那么多的东西来修饰自己的生活。
没有膨胀的消费主义与欲望。
就是很简单的美丽的东方式的一种审美。
呈现给了所有人
然后用这种美征服了所有人。
就像这个East demo 有没有我嘛？
然后永远在冲击
我觉得梦就是这样的一个东西。
我觉得这种美其实是可以跨越文化。
跨越政治经济的
它就是一种非常直观的视觉上的美。
可以让所有人喜欢。
而且我觉得梦这个元素。
它本身就是非常中国的一个东西。
就我们刚才说到梦嘛？
我觉得可以再稍微延伸一点。
我一直觉得梦是一个特别中式的一个文化的元素。
那你比如说日本人可能这一点没有那么强。
就是说梦合这一点。
可能不是他们特别主流的一个点。
对吧？
他们可能更喜欢误挨。
叉技这样的一个状态。
更加极简的一个风格。
但是中国
你像很多的文化
穆丹亭
杜丽娘和柳梦梅
他们的这个关系
杜丽娘的这个一场春梦。
让她体会到了爱情。
然后开启了一个少女的芳心。
我觉得中国文化传承哪怕到现在。
她其中这种遥远的感觉和割裂的感觉。
结合在一起的时候。
其实是很适合用梦境这个语系去描述她的嘛？
就比如最近很火的那个Rap。
大展红图
大家可能都觉得她是一个洗脑神曲。
但是有一说一我也特别喜欢。
我很喜欢她开头来乐剧采样。
然后在后面作为她选立主动机的那个部分。
以及她所有的Rap歌词都在描述一种。
带有中国传统色彩的声方方式的内容。
所以这个歌曲
我确实也听过很多其他的洗脑神曲。
但是这个歌曲就深刻的印在了我的脑子里。
那我也想通过这个例子来证明。
就是说确实
中式跟梦合这个东西是有非常高的匹配度的。
嗯 除了梦合 除了梦境这样的元素。
你像可希勋和尚田一燕他们会运用到的妆发。
还有这些比较偏红 棕色的这种色彩。
它都是能够非常强化中国元素的一种视觉风格。
我们其实展开了这么多 聊了这么多。
其实我们都在讨论就是说。
当我们在聊世界的摄影。
什么欧美 马格南的摄影。
日本的摄影的时候。
我们中国人自己的摄影风格在哪。
我们作为摄影师
无论你是拍商业的还是拍艺术的。
甚至你就是一个个人的创作者。
你在拍些什么？
因为我们没有办法去改变的一点。
就是我的母语就是中文。
然后我就是从这样的一个文化背景里成长起来的。
然后我们可能经历了过去的那一波又一波的改变。
然后走到今天
然后如果我再去回看沉重的历史或者说不远的过去。
那我如何用影像
如何用这种现代化的艺术和工具去展现非常中国式的视觉语言。
然后让世界的人理解。
最终真正能够形成一种就是属于中国人自己的中国风格的摄影。
我觉得这个其实是聊了这么多。
其实想要表达的一个点吧？
回到这个广告系列里来。
我在研究调查找资料看了这么多之后。
其实确实是更佩服葛西勋一点的。
因为它是牢牢的把上天宴这种梦感遥远感的风格。
按在中国这个主题上的那个决策者。
他知道这个东西这两个东西捆绑在一起是他想要的。
那确实他也做到了成功了。
他让日本市场对这个广告超级有印象。
有印象到可能这么一个连续30年的项目。
然后影响了日本不止一代人。
大家想象一下
如果你10岁的时候看到电视上有一个饮料广告。
说着你听不懂的中文。
然后最后出一个乌龙茶。
等你到了40岁的时候。
这个乌龙茶广告依然在这么表达一个东西。
那这个时候中国这个概念应该很深刻的就已经被植入到了观众的脑子里。
很多日本观众在认识中国的时候。
也都深刻的被这一30年的乌龙茶广告所影响到了。
其实我还挺羡慕他们的视角的。
就是他其实是有一定的距离去拍摄的。
然后去创作的嘛？
然后有的时候我们可能难以提炼出这个东西。
或是属于我们自己的故乡的。
我们自己这片土地的元素。
可能也是因为我们身处其中。
所以可能有的时候你需要跳出来一点点。
然后以一个稍微局外人一点的视角去捕捉。
这个心态会更好一点。
那很多日本观众可能都受到这个广告影响去中国旅游了。
因为他看到这个画面以后就说。
哇这个地方好美
我要去这里我要看到它。
然后有很多人因为听不懂这个歌和对白。
所以他去学了中文。
我觉得这可能也是这几个广告的创作者没想到的一个特点。
就是说他已经成了一种文化沟通的载体了。
但我觉得在这里我就想来讨论另一个点。
就是说广告摄影
其实现在很多时候是容易被人比义的。
因为所有人对广告摄影第一反应就是它不真实。
它不客观
它所传达的信息是被资本做局过的。
那我觉得今天讲的三德丽乌龙产的这个系列广告。
其实就很好的反驳了这个视角。
就是说广告摄影它可能是更大众的。
它是更经练过信息的。
但是它也可以是真的。
它也可以是美的
就比如三德丽这个广告里传递出的中国。
首先它很优美
我作为一个中国人。
我可能都没见过很多在它广告里展现出来的那种美景的画面。
我可能看到太多老法师所拍的那种。
山青水秀大美那那那的这些摄影风格了。
但是其实我也想看到更接近中国传统山水的。
我想看到更加暗调。
然后低宝盒色彩更加传统中国。
像国画里面一样的一些表达。
我也想看到很漂亮的模特在这个场景里。
它能做出的一些行为是什么样子的。
这都能激发我对中国这个概念。
对美这个概念的一种愉快的感觉。
嗯是的
这一套广告就是长达30年的广告。
我们回顾下来给我最深的一个感动就是它很中国。
就像比如说当我们去提到东京的时候。
我会想起三山大道。
当我提到密西西比的时候。
我也想到Alexors。
那当我提到中国的时候。
我想到北京我想到上海的时候。
嗯留给我的影像到底是什么？
那我觉得这是一个问号。
它应该是那些非常苦大仇深。
或者是非常模仿某种类型的。
某种学院拍的风格吗？
那我们自己到底能够创作出什么样的影像。
我们应该记录什么？
反正我是每天都都在深刻的思考这个问题。
那同样是拍摄中国。
然后同样是长达很多年的拍摄。
其实我们是有一些参照戏可以拿出来聊的。
比如布列松
布列松拍摄的中国在中国被禁了。
中国政府不喜欢他拍的中国。
因为布列松是传统马格南的视角。
他认为我要拍到人民真实的生活不加以任何修饰。
然后那么之后呢？
同样身为马格南成员的九宝天博二。
也拍了中国
东亚人之间沟通是能懂面子这个事情的。
他会很给中国的生活部门面子。
他会拍很多那种像地方政府旅游宣传一样的画面。
然后他也会拍人很阳光积极的那个状态。
所以大家也可以看到他的那边早春的中国。
这两年也在中国的书店里都拜得很满。
到了上天宴所拍的这个永远要充景。
拍的三头地广告
他就不中国嘛？
我个人是觉得他甚至比马格南这两位摄影师。
呈现出来的更接近一个真实的中国或者说本质的中国。
因为首先他是一个团队作业。
他被人操控了
说如果这个东西太有你个人的想法的话。
他会被删掉
那这其实是很中国的一个创作过程。
我喜欢葛西勋把上天宴控制住的感觉。
我喜欢他摁着他
一定要拍出中国味的中国的那种感觉。
对而且我觉得发展性的这种画面也是非常中国的呀？
对吧如果你非要去拍一个揭露性的。
非常新闻性的
你如果说新闻他就是真实的嘛？
我作为一个学新闻的人告诉你不是。
尤其是国际和国际间的这种新闻报道。
他其实很多背后都是舆论机器。
都是国家的意志所操纵的。
他不一定就是真实对吗？
就是你如何去看待影像中照片中的这种真实性。
我觉得这个观点也应该是与时俱进的。
那我觉得可能很多人会强调说。
这个东西必须是真实的。
终于历史的
终于这个事情如何发生又如何结束的这样一个状态。
被刻画进影像里面。
这个影像才能被称之为可靠的。
才是高尚的才是值得被传送的。
但实际上从广告摄影里我们可以看到。
如果我们把一个商业项目认真的坚持它。
然后把它提炼成更简炼的状态。
去表达一个东西的话。
它也可以具备记录时代的能力。
我们可以从三德丽这套广告里看到中国的变迁是什么样子的。
同时它永远展现的是一种积极的感觉。
那么作为一个相对于这些广告的诞生。
很靠后的一个后人来讲。
那我觉得我的感受是幸好有这个东西。
把很美的一面流传给了我。
因为很不好的一面很容易被摧毁掉。
但是简单的美好是能一直流传下来的。
所以比如我们想记录下。
现在眼前我生活中经历的一切。
去传承下去被所有人所理解。
是很难的一个事情。
因为这带有一个太个人的角度和价值观。
以及你C了很多的政治、经济、文化、个人主义的元素在里面了。
当然广告这个载地很巧妙。
广告这个载地可能是想要做简法。
把一切东西简化到只有一个概念。
只有一个核心传递给观众。
争取最多数人的最小限度的共识。
这个时候广告的传播力和保存能力是会是更好的。
以上就是我们关于三德丽乌龙茶。
从1984年一直到2011年。
将近30年的时间以中国为主题在中国的创作。
也希望能够给大家带来一些关于中国这个主题的创作思路。
我们为了制作这一期节目。
同样也是做了很多功课。
找了很多的资料
然后我们会尽量把更多的图片放在收诺词里。
然后大家在这一期所收听到的所有的歌曲、配乐。
也都是那个年代的所有的广告里面的插曲。
希望大家喜欢
好的，以上就是本期节目的主要内容。
如果大家喜欢这期节目的话。
欢迎大家点赞、评论、转发、收藏。
甚至打赏一下
来表达一下你对这期节目的看法。
那我们就进入到每期必有的这个彩蛋环节吧？
我来介绍一下乌龙茶这个广告系列的一个分支吧？
就是黑乌龙茶
黑乌龙茶系列其实我觉得是更有设计感的一个样板。
因为乌龙茶可能更多的是以上天宴作为一个摄影师。
为主去主导的项目。
大家看到的这种变迁、表达。
也更多是跟摄影很有关的。
但是黑乌龙茶这个系列其实更设计。
那么这个系列它开启于2006年左右。
它同样也是由可惜勋和上天宴去拍的。
因为就是一个支线产品嘛？
但是它这时候选用的演员和场景是比较有趣的。
它选用了上海的剧团里面。
甚至里面有人去演过老娘舅的那种本地演员。
然后那么黑乌龙茶系列它的卖点。
就是说这个东西能挂油。
这个东西能削减你对脂肪的吸收。
但是日本是一个保健食品。
那么这个时候他们选择老演员。
就是希望他们去穿黑色的中山装。
去扮演老干部的这个形象。
然后同时整个画面其实是由红、黑、白去构成的。
其实也是非常传统中国的这个色系嘛？
你会看到在白底上的这个黑色书法。
也会看到这个非常红透着虎破色的这个黑乌龙茶的样子。
这个系列其实也拍了很久。
同时对日本观众也很热烈。
我也把它放在双脑子的最后。
大家也可以看一下它在设计上会有一种更公整的美感。
那今天这一整期呢？
其实讲的都是关于广告摄影的内容。
那我最后也给自己打个广告吧？
希望大家可以关注一下我的小红书。
因为我最近已经开始在小红书上面更新一些翻画册的视频。
也希望这些视频能够和我们的播客内容有关。
也希望这些视频呢能够和我们的播客内容形成一个互补。
给大家在另外一个平台提供更多视觉上的内容。
就是能够方便大家多看到一些东西吧？
我的小红书账号呢就是dodolou小写的。
然后后面跟上镜雅这两个汉字。
然后大家就能找到。
我尽量去给大家翻一些我们最新买到的一些。
我非常喜欢的影集。
一些比如说我们非常喜欢的摄影师的这个江姐和介绍也会在这样的视频里面呈现。
我们其实还是觉得说视频它更多还是展现就是你看到了什么嘛？
然后那播客其实它能承载的信息量是非常非常大的。
所以就是比如说类似今天的这种内容会需要更多思考的。
更多背景信息的内容一定是放在播客里讲的。
然后关于更多的视频图片这样的内容会放到小红书的账号里面来。
所以希望大家多多支持。
然后也希望能够给大家呈现更多丰富的内容。
然后大家也可以关注一下我的小红书号。
那么我的小红书账号现在叫海鲁的怀鲁。
大家在关注完镜雅之后也可以顺便来关注我一下。
因为我是想做一下直播内容的。
因为我觉得很多大家在评论区里的问题。
或者说有一些话题适合讨论的。
它可能更适合直播这种形式。
所以也请大家多多关注我一下。
好那么以上就是本期节目的全部内容。
我们下期再见
再见
学习第一本书